let's make this easy to make mango Mochi
ice cream start by portioning out your
favorite mango ice cream then freezing
for at least one hour next make the
Mochi by adding these ingredients to a
bowl and stirring until combined cover
the bowl then microwave for one minute
stir to mix well then microwave in 30
second intervals until the consistency
of the Mochi looks smooth and shiny like
this dust your surface in the Mochi ball
with cornstarch and once cool to the
touch roll out to a quarter inch thick
portion out four squares then add ice
cream to the center fold in the corners
and shape into a ball
freeze for one hour and enjoy